look who it is
what up george hey ready for another
night
hotel emma baby yeah maybe what sweet we
at
i don't know but it's on the top floor
i'm just getting the king sweet
george sweet
we're out here today we'll see what we
get into
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[ __ ]
god
damn
what is this the king has made it baby
hey ladies it's welcome
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's up just soaking up the rays
of beautiful san antonio on this
saturday the crew flew me out came to
see brendan schaub tonight outside of
the san antonio spurs where they play i
got the legs out soaking today you know
how it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
before i close out tonight i gotta bring
this gentleman on stage his name's
george he's all the way from chicago let
me tell you about george real quick
george a year
my man george here a year and a half ago
on king of the steam sent a submission
in and he was
yeah man
[Applause]
george
was 450 pounds and he said dude if i
lose 200 pounds i'll fly to l.a and i
will wrestle stevie i went dude you lose
200 [ __ ] pounds i will fly to l.a i
will fly you to my show have you
backstage
this is george
george
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey bubbas
just got back from san antonio
i got to stay at the hotel emma in the
king suite i got to see b
live got to see chappelle derek poston
david lucas i don't think words could
express how much i appreciate brendan
schaub
he is the most genuine kind human i've
ever met
and
it doubles off the camera as you have
truly changed my life and showed a young
man
from the midwest
that there's so many beautiful things in
this world and if i keep [ __ ] working
as hard as i have been
then we got this [ __ ]
i hope you guys have an awesome night
day of growth um it's a day of uh
just um moving forward in my life so i'm
getting rid of thelma
um
today uh
i spent many of nights with her
um and she lived in my closet
this is a very hard day
um
but i wish you the best
but i can't you i can't live you can't
leave my closet anymore
hold on i still want to do a
prayer thank you